our next guest is known for his
outstanding work at ESPN the NFL Network
James K Polk high school proud Michigan
graduate who has shown great resiliency
he comes back every year after his
Wolverines failed to do so against Ohio
State we're especially grateful that he
went so far out of his way to come here
given his set is about 30 yards away
please welcome Rich Eisen now music well
no it was just an introduction I spent
all the money on that we gave you the
bowls introduction I take down all sorts
of pillow sitting up here and hey wait
are you kvetching around convention yes
it is South Florida what is your
favorite Yiddish word oh gosh um I think
fetching is pretty good that's a good
one meshuggenah Michigan is great look
at you feeding me Yiddish word look at
judge not much novice which is joy you
give me joy I get joy who wrote that for
you good yontiff good you would say that
to me all the time whenever I sat down
whenever i sat down doing sports and I
would sit down before the you just look
at me good you know it's because I had a
Jewish producer for I don't know how
many years five years right and he we
were in New York yeah he said you might
need to know some Yiddish and I go when
am I gonna need to know yentas right and
then I got to the diamond district to
buy my engagement ring for my wife and
knowing yet help till they came in it
came in got a little cut said good
yontiff when I wanted to buy my
engagement my wife they didn't give me a
discount though so what happened the
Sandler movie uncut gems yeah I know
that feeling of going into the diamond
district again I have not seen that yet
I need to see it I heard it's great he
did a wonderful job and and I felt bad
for him he didn't get nominated but I
said but you're the underdog like it
might be bad for your brand if you
actually got nominated writers
I felt bad that's that's the way you're
comfortable it's good for you yeah that
you didn't get nominated because your
brand is yeah you'd never get nominated
and that's that's basically a great way
to my way there for your friend well how
would you feel if somebody says hey it's
great you didn't get nominated for a
Sports it's good for your brain okay
you're substandard or you're low rent
okay so but great oh great which one of
you guys wrote it McLovin McLovin huh
Michigan Greta what's to get back you
give me a hard time
who texted you in the middle of the game
oh my god I've seen you since that like
physically seeing you you guys just want
to recap this anything you want to say
time well I mean I'll recap it for those
who are just joining us certainly the
studio audience here that Michigan is
playing army and as it turned out the
win-loss kind of didn't matter anyway
for their national championship hopes as
we subsequently found out leading to the
dig that mclovin Road for Dan to lead me
into this chair that you know I'm at my
son's soccer game my phone is literally
on half a percent of battery I'm hoping
that the way I'm following it through
the app watching this little football
the way it moves around on the screen
how it affects my emotion so greatly and
I get a text from from fritz Tyco in the
big house thanks for the update okay
fritz ease nickname is Captain Obvious
yes and Captain Obvious struck he's need
to let him know I was watching and I was
feeling for him in the spill cos and the
anger over what was might happen
you're not it doesn't sound like that it
feels like you're rubbing it in when you
say
and I mean I feel bad because I do see
some Orange Crush fans over there but I
was waiting for a similar big moment for
the Broncos to play out this season for
me to exact my revenge and nothing ever
materialized unfortunately I was loaned
out way before I got that in my back
pocket for when drew Locke does actually
do what it seems like he has the ability
to do but so yes good to see you again
all right we spent way too much time in
the first time we're talking about the
Chargers the Philip Rivers - yeah I
think Philip Rivers moved on from the
Chargers literally since he moved to
Florida right and then I had a source
who said to me keep an eye on the Colts
for Philip Rivers sure I mean the Colts
if you want to make complete and total
sense of it is the best spot in Dungey
I'm sure is said some other things on
your show as he said on mine the best
landing spot for Tom Brady is
Indianapolis that team is ready to win
this year they were ready to win with
their 12 if he didn't retire and if
Brady doesn't retire which he's not
going to the perfect spot for him to
enter with a situation that is all set
up is Indianapolis yeah but and doesn't
make sense for Philip Rivers to end up
with the pole sure I mean yeah they need
a veteran presence one would think at
quarterback but Phillip Phillip needs to
in the last minutes of a game take
better care of the football I don't
think his teammates were the ones who
were although I don't I shouldn't say
that I haven't looked at the all 22 Dan
but sometimes an interception is on the
quarterback sometimes it is not but
Phillip would be a great spot for
Indianapolis anybody that can come there
and maybe bring a veteran presence in a
may in a way that perset did not would
be a perfect fit right there and I look
the way things work in the NFL is
seasons over
they have exit interviews they sit down
I'm sure Phillip was told we're not
going in this direction everybody kept
it quiet because of the obvious
sensitivities
and Philip decided let's go move back
closer to home in Alabama and went wound
up from all what I'm hearing is in Tampa
and that would obviously be a
fascinating situation as to what their
quarterback future is there but it was
obvious that the two of them found out
from each other that were done and to me
living in Los Angeles my three beautiful
children never talked about Chargers
football to me never once not at all I
mean they'll see a Rams game you'll see
a Chargers game and they'll stop for a
Rams game because they know the Rams are
in Los Angeles they have not gone to
that make shift if you will soccer slash
football facility that the Chargers been
playing and if Brady shows up in Los
Angeles my three kids would demand a
powder-blue 12 on the spot and that is a
fact that is an absolute fact in all of
Los Angeles would stop what they are
doing and say huh the Chargers like yeah
they've been here for three years yeah
and that's what Brady would bring to the
equation the question is obviously all
the moving parts in New England yeah
that's what I'm trying to figure this
out if the Patriots want him back
according to Robert Kraft Brady wants to
go back then why won't this happen
because of something we're not
completely familiar with I think 20
years of the relationship I don't know I
don't know if it is a roster concern
that unfortunately can't be addressed
prior to when the failsafe moment of
having to sign this contract is it's
right at the new league year big they
they have shown that they went out and
they did get an Tonio Brown and
obviously we know why that didn't work
out they did get Josh Gordon we know why
that didn't work out so they could say
the track record we coughed up a to
force anew which rhymes and and that
didn't work out so they tried but if its
roster concerns and he does look over
the steering wheel and sees what he's
got in New England and again Mike
Williams Keenan Allen Eckler underhand
Orton and Hunter Henry and then on
defense Bosa and Ingram and Erwin James
I mean that is a serious roster
you have to consider is ready to win in
a two to three year window that Brady
even with his superhuman anti-aging
ability has left you'd have to sit there
and think that and how does the break-up
happen to me that is once this game is
over these story and if it's Garoppolo
winning it all
would make that story even more
significant because we in the media and
many other people will forget that after
they traded Garoppolo away yeah Brady
did win two of the next four right so
they did get what they needed out of it
you know the Patriots regret getting rid
of Jimmy Garoppolo not when they're
hoisting to super oh if you said you
could go you could say to Belichick hey
you're gonna get two Super Bowls in the
next four years but you got to lose
Jimmy Garoppolo see you yeah yeah but
we're making it seem like oh man they
made a mistake by getting rid of
Garoppolo no I mean they got what they
wanted and one of the years they didn't
win it they were in the Super Bowl so
they made it three out of four years so
all that said once this game is over and
we were looking over the steering wheel
looking at the combine in two and a half
weeks which is amazing how quick it
shows up we will be looking at the brady
story what's going on and how do with
all the young pieces fit I know two is
coming on both of our shows later this
week Joe Joe borough as well
Herbert where does he go there's other
quarterbacks that are rising as they say
and how do they all fit and what does
that mean for Phillip for Brady and I
think breeze comes back in place for New
Orleans I know he says he's got a
process that he's going through I would
be stunned that doesn't happen unless
he's got a TV job that's true that's the
only thing that there is that what I
mean and you know III know it is an
occupied spot in the Monday Night
Football booth right now
but where does Romo go does he go
somewhere would Brees take that job on
Monday night and the fact that the rumor
always was that yes Payton wants to run
a franchise but he would haven't been
interested in the Monday night booth
if not for the fact that at some point
in a blowout game we'd have to turn to
paint and go so Daniel Jones just got
the job in New York what do you think
and it would put him in a very difficult
spot now that as it we all know is no
longer an issue that will be an
interesting media spot and how this
might all play out Rich Eisen host of
their chosen show NFL Network host who's
on the guest list later on today later
on today Deon will walk over and also we
got Steve Smith senior Frank Caliendo
Jorge Masvidal will stop by and we'll
talk a little bit of oble ISM Eric
Stonestreet was on you you Skyped with
the the great actor from Modern Family
City chief fan yeah he's he's got a beef
with me he does I don't know if he knows
the real story of he doesn't okay or
based on your read of it that once the
AFC Championship game was over you know
I called all of my friends who are
Chiefs fans he is one of them and I I
facetimed him because you know I'm a
face to face guy and I'd like to see
when he was celebrating and he was
already full celebration mode as we all
know the NFC champion team happened
after long story short there's several
members of the offensive line of the
Kansas City Chiefs reveling with Eric
and all of them say that you owe them
dinner because the Chiefs were better
than the Chargers and you say you took
the Chiefs all year no I took the Chiefs
of ICH you know that right so there's a
all I know again is that is that we and
the media I guess we're all painted with
one large brush by the people that we
cover one of the players screamed that I
owed him dinner and I'm like what are
you talking about in Stonestreet goes no
no that's not dan Patrick that's Rich
Eisen and Dan's the one who owes his
dinner and they all widely agreed and
all of them had nothing but derision for
you
based on their facial expressions so
there is a disconnect here and a bridge
to divide an eye you know bring it on
stone street he's coming
what's coming no I mean but they're all
they all think that now this said if it
was a 2018 wager yeah where you said
your chargers would be better than the
Chiefs
yes you still lose because they made the
AFC champion team and the Chargers did
not yeah so both sides could be right
that I'm more than happy to take him to
spar oh well Fritz East went there he
said the CD is great it is yes yeah it
does lead his fan in Airport known right
across the street from our hotel right
across the street there's a haagen-dazs
or take them out for dessert it's good
you just go right down the road right
there but I'll take care account for for
dinner look I don't want to get involved
I would just wanted to give you a heads
up because I'm friends with you um
friends with him I don't wanna be caught
in the middle it's really awkward Dan
okay I'm just I
I'm with the Chiefs this year you're all
in yes we're gonna win so let's all just
get along why don't we just hug it out
and then we move on I think that'll be a
wonderful moment for you on Friday's
show there could be tears and then seven
and a half hour pregame seven a half
hour pregame show at work 9:00 in the
morning yeah and I will be there for all
seven and a half hours yeah I might do
one of those like you know live-action
photographs to see how I progressed in
it Scorsese to do that anti-aging he did
yeah look like you're 26 that's exactly
right I'll do that
the De Niro of post game show host thank
you for stopping by as always let me
Jason four more Dan Patrick show tune in
to audience Channel 239 on DirecTV
stream for free on BR live or download
the Dan Patrick show app
[Music]